[Music]
hey guys the final season of game
internals will come to the screens in
the first scaffold 2019 is all they've
known for cern until today rumors have
been floating around about the airdate
and HBO finally confirmed it with the
launch of for the throne campaign the
last season will debut in April 2019 has
tagged for the throne campaign that
finally revealed the airdate is here to
promote the final six episodes of Game
of Thrones it's a multi-phase global
marketing campaign that will unfold over
the months leading into the final season
the campaign started today with the
supercut showcasing highlights from the
show space together with a small gift in
the premiere date along the videos we'll
also be getting character posters shared
across official game internal social
media profiles that highlight what main
characters have done for the throne
additionally Twitter has also designed a
custom emoji to celebrate the final
season there are 5 hashtags you can use
to unlock this so go and fit something
after you've done watching this video
but make sure to use hashtag game
appearance or hashtag for the throne to
unlock the emoji game experience we'll
also be taking over New York City's
Grand Central Station beginning on
November 27th with over 150 variations
of the hashtag for the term creative
notions in a limited edition run of
250,000 Metro cards it might not be a
trailer or teaser but it's at least
something in finally received during
this long wait
hopefully the official trailer job soon
speaking of it I'd say it will drop on
December 21st the first official day of
winter beside the premiere date nothing
else is known except for how the
premiere will look like Entertainment
Weekly provided the first exclusive look
at what's to come in the next season of
Game Jones
teaser includes a detail description of
the opening scene the largest battle
scene ever filmed for not only game
girls but for the television in general
and the mysterious scene from the very
finale the opening scene will see the
arrival of John and Danny with their
crews have interval which is said to be
similar to King Robert's arrival in a
series premiere this episode will be an
episode full of reunions so if you just
like me happy waiting for some of the
main characters to finally reunite
you'll finally get it in the very
episode of the final season beside many
Iranians premiere will also feature many
tense first meetings between characters
with a highlight of sense and not being
thrilled with Jon bending the knee to a
Targaryen or at least not at first
according to Peter Dinklage an actor we
know as Tyrion Lannister the upcoming
battle from interval between the living
and that makes the battle the bastards
look like a theme park and the last but
not least the scene from a series finale
is also described it's noted that there
are characters in the last episode of
Game of Thrones we don't expect in
you want to hear more information
regarding this I'll read it is quite a
big breakdown of all this if you haven't
seen it already make sure to do so we
also did a theory regarding who the
mystery character from the Game of
Thrones finale might be the one we don't
expect to see so you might want to check
that as well anyways well we do know
small details from the premiere nothing
is known about the finale the ending of
Game of Thrones except for it featuring
a character that will make us freak out
however what we do know is that it could
be a divisive finale sophie turner an
actress that portrays sense a stark
hinted that have the final episode might
leave fans feeling to be able to act out
the way that it all ends it was really
satisfying for us she said and continued
with who knows if it will be satisfying
for advance I think a lot of fans will
be disappointed that a lot of fans will
be over the moon I think this could mean
that some of the fans favorite
characters might die which would surely
leave some of the fans disappointed well
on the other hand leaving others
satisfied with have the character's
story completed and came together it
could also mean that for example we
won't ever find out the night King's
true intentions especially keeping in
mind that game occurrence prequel will
be about the first long night which
would definitely make most of the fans
upset ok guys that'll do for this short
video the final season of Game of
Thrones airs in April 2019 and as always
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see in the
next time peace
[Music]